a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
return of the jedi had yet to be
released what did people think was going
to happen what was spoiler culture like
and how did critics describe jabba the
hut to people who hadn't seen him yet
here's what it was really like to see
return of the jedi in 1983. some movie
series open to mediocre reception and
find their legacy years later as cult
classics but that was not the case with
star wars the first two films had become
cultural phenomenons and audiences
eagerly awaited return of the jedi the
final installment of the original
trilogy think back to the excitement in
the air on the opening night of
spider-man no way home another
three-quarter or even the rise of
skywalker the third of the star wars
sequel trilogy films this isn't a new
thing audiences in 1983 did the same
thing we do in 2022 totally geek out at
the movies
long before electronic seat reservations
were standard or even fathomable fans in
los angeles waited outside their theater
for days prior to the midnight debut of
return of the jedi on may 25th 1983 and
by days we mean days we've been here for
six days and it's great
and why wouldn't they after all the
previous film the empire strikes back
and left everyone with the cliffhanger
that darth vader was luke's father what
could possibly follow that revelation in
1983 the denver post claimed that return
of the jedi was quote one of the most
anticipated movies of all time sharing a
photo of moviegoers waiting outside in
costume as their favorite characters
adoration for this galaxy far far away
has truly been bringing people together
for generations
one of the most satisfying things about
being a devoted fan of something whether
it be a show or a book series or in this
case star wars is being in on all the
inside jokes and lesser known deets
these days the sheer amount of stuff to
geek out on is endless but back in 1983
possessing deep knowledge about any
given pop culture phenomenon was a
little more novel of an experience that
being said if you were there on opening
night to return to the jedi you would
have seen numerous in the know fans
wearing shirts bearing the original
title of the trilogy's epic conclusion
yep you heard us right as it turns out
return of the jedi was originally titled
revenge of the jedi oh i'm sorry did i
break your concentration
and this wasn't just an internal
temporary name that was changed before
announcing the movie to the public
either it made it so far in the
post-production process that the first
trailer for the movie advertised revenge
of the jedi to prospective audiences
eventually revenge was swapped for
return and the rest is of course movie
history a good idea never really goes
away though because in 2005 the removed
word would finally make its way into a
star wars movie with the release of star
wars episode 3 revenge of the sith
we've all been there you innocently log
into twitter around 8am and start
scrolling only to find that some guy
just had to be the first one to drop
spoilers about the new episode of the
mandalorian that dropped in the middle
of the night
what else did he say
or maybe a headline unashamedly gives
away the end credit scene of eternals
you get mad when someone spoils a movie
or television show before you've gotten
a chance to see it
dodging spoilers is an art but it's not
a new practice while 1983 audiences may
not have been avoiding tweets they had
means of their own to be wary of when
return of the jedi debuted in footage
from a 1983 newscast recorded seemingly
on opening night an audience member
spills that darth vader shows his face
to luke the big surprise was seeing
darth vader unveil himself to his son it
was very exciting in the series until
this point darth vader had very much
been masked and cloaked with no
intention or even mention of ever taking
off his signature attire news that he
appears in return of the jedi in some
sort of visually revealing way would
have been a major spoiler elsewhere in
the same set of interviews another
audience member reveals that the movie
ends in celebration while this perhaps
could have been predicted by those who
knew the movie was a finale to a trilogy
even a happy ending wasn't necessarily
guaranteed and still would have at least
been a minor spoiler watch out viewers
of the nightly news
perhaps unsurprisingly given the extreme
popularity for all things star wars from
the series inception in 1977 return of
the jedi did wonders at the box office
and made history the new york times
excitedly broke the news a few days
later that the movie's opening day may
25 1983 earned 6.2 million dollars the
biggest opening day in movie history at
that time it beat the previous record
held by 1982 star trek 2 the wrath of
khan despite the phenomenon that star
wars clearly was the times noted the
success of return of the jedi was
further more impressive because its
release date was a wednesday rather than
the traditional friday opening even on a
weeknight nothing was going to keep
audiences away from seeing what happened
next for luke skywalker or han solo
over my dead body in keeping with
tradition future star wars films would
achieve the same feat when perusing box
office mojo's list the biggest opening
day box offices we can see other movies
in the series after return of the jedi
broke opening day records at the time of
their respective releases including
1999's the phantom menace 2005's revenge
of the sith and 2015's the force awakens
it can be difficult to please everyone
when it comes to sequels especially if
it's the last entry in the series this
is especially evident when considering
the contradictory opinions from critics
upon the release of return of the jedi
for instance the hollywood reporter
lamented to be sure of the film a
balance in action some new peril besets
luke skywalker han solo or princess leia
almost too regularly every 10 minutes
but there's a kind of desperation about
it a feeling that lucas and co-writer
lawrence kazdan are simply trying to
figure out what they can do next to
amuse the kitties by contrast the
washington post couldn't sing the film's
praises enough saying return of the jedi
a feat of mass enchantment puts the
happy finishing touches on george
lucas's star wars saga it was worth the
wait and the work is now an imposing
landmark in contemporary popular culture
it's all water under the bridge now of
course but it's nonetheless fascinating
to wonder how these differing
perspectives affected the expectations
of those who had yet to see the
trilogy's conclusion in the theaters for
the very first time
outside of broad opinions of the film
it's also interesting to take into
account how critics were faced with
teasing details from return of the jedi
without saying too much
how does one describe job in the hut to
someone who hasn't seen the movie yet
critic roger ebert summed up the
infamous intergalactic crime lord as
such
jabba is a slimy gruesome reptilian
monster made of warts and teeth a cross
between a toad and the cheshire cat
looking back from our current
perspective we'd say that's quite a
visceral description that still leaves a
lot to the imagination the british film
institute's description poetically plays
off of ebert's labeling jabba as quote
imposingly repellent and a toad inflated
to nightmarish complacency on the other
hand the hollywood reporter kept things
relatively vague describing jabba as
quote truly frightening and gross
regardless of which review fans happen
to stumble upon in the lead up to their
initial viewing experience it goes
without saying that no collection of
words can quite do java justice you just
have to see the sadistic oversized slug
for yourself
in 1983 jabba the hutt and the denizens
of his secluded desert palace weren't
the only cosmic creatures on moviegoers
minds just one year prior steven
spielberg's e.t the extraterrestrial had
become a huge hit
e
t
home phone
while e.t and return of the jedi are
quite different audiences might have
felt a similar euphoria while viewing
both movies
star log magazine highlighted reader
reviews shortly after jedi debuted ryan
richards from minnesota wrote to the
publication this is the first film since
i saw e.t that made me feel real good
inside i left the theater with my spirit
soaring return of the jedi is destined
to become a classic
other readers were not so enthused by
the trilogy's conclusion and mockingly
compared it to shall we say less serious
monuments of pop culture frank gerard
from new jersey wrote return of the jedi
was an overwhelming disappointment i
simply cannot believe george lucas has
given to eager star wars fans everywhere
a film which belongs on the muppet show
or saturday morning tv in the end though
most fans were simply blown away barb
trimble from mississippi gushed this
movie is a non-stop ride on that star
wars roller coaster you barely have time
to settle back in your seats after a
white knuckler of a scene then it's off
again for round two bravo george
while it's true that return of the jedi
was the final movie in the original star
wars trilogy there was plenty more yet
to come and audiences knew this even in
1983 it was public knowledge that george
lucas intended to make nine star wars
movies and that return of the jedi was
placed as sixth in the story quite the
ambitious undertaking to reveal to the
general public nonetheless it would be
16 years before the story expanded when
1999's the phantom menace kicked off the
prequel trilogy
there's always a bigger fish while 1983
moviegoers might have known more star
wars was on the way they didn't expect
luke leia or han solo to ever re-enter
the narrative thanks to roger ebert's
1983 review he said if george lucas
persists in his plan to make 9 star wars
movies this will nevertheless be the
last we'll see of luke khan and leia
although the robots will be present in
all the films the droids would indeed
continue to make appearances but so
would the three original leads even if
it took a bit longer for them to return
to the series
return of the jedi was more than just a
movie to some of its viewers inspired by
its character story and filmmaking
technique some audience members in 1983
left the theater feeling inspired to
make movies of their own this included
brad bird who at the time was 25 years
old and working as an animator at disney
bird would later direct the iron giant
and the incredibles among other films in
the forward of the 2013 edition of the
book the making of return of the jedi
bird shares that he snuck into a
lucasfilm crew screening of return of
the jedi and marveled at seeing the film
in the same room as george lucas and
director richard marquand bird writes i
was now surrounded by the very geniuses
who had brought this rarest of cinematic
sagas to a satisfying conclusion grand
style
however bird wasn't wild about
everything in the movie specifically
feeling like luke's character had made
an unrealistic leap from the hero in
training he was at the end of the empire
strikes back to the competent
protagonists he suddenly appeared to be
by the beginning of return of the jedi
bird reflects
the point is not that i or any other fan
agree with every single choice george
has made in telling his epic saga the
point is that we care
there are shall we say polarizing
creative choices within the star wars
universe that fans have different
perspectives on while today it's easy to
look back on films that are considered
classics and assume that nothing was
controversial at the time of their
release return of the jedi actually put
fans at odds when it came to a new
creature the film introduced ewoks
point that thing someplace else
the cuddly bear-like animals on the moon
of endor turned out to be quite the
soldiers when faced with threats in 1983
audiences were divided in what they
thought of ewoks and how they welcomed
them or didn't into the series
some audience members criticized the
ewoks as being nothing but a marketing
device to sell toys the subject it seems
was something of a hot topic among fans
in the 80s good thing we've moved on
past those kinds of petty squabbles
about things that we claim ruined star
wars right
[Laughter]
just kidding ewoks are definitely still
a divisive subject to this day love them
or hate them though the ewoks went on to
star in their own made for tv movies and
animated tv series and none of it would
have happened without return of the jedi
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you